welcome and thank you for joining us at  noon i'm bianca holman we begin with the  news out of new york today as governor  andrew cuomo has resigned amid sexual  harassment allegation so his decision  will take effect in two weeks and it  comes as cause for him to step down grew  louder as well as impeachment threats  loomed last week new york attorney's  attorney's general released the results  of an investigation that found cuomo  sexually harassed at least 11 women  cuomo thanked those women for coming  forward today  i want to thank the women who came  forward with sincere complaints  it's not easy to step forward  but you did an important service  and you taught me  and you taught others an important  lesson  personal boundaries must be expanded  and must be protected  i accept full  responsibility lieutenant governor kathy  hojo will take over when his recognition  is effective and cuomo said the  transition must be seamless